Write 6 times 6 times 6 times
6 times 6 times 6 times 6
times 6 in exponential
notation.
So what's going on over here?
Well, we have 6 multiplied
by itself how many times?
Let's see, that's 6 times 1,
then 6 times 2 is that.
That's 6 times-- well,
it's not 6 times 2.
It's 6 times itself two times.
Remember, 6 times itself
two times would be 36.
6 times 2 would only be 12.
So we have one 6, two 6, three
6, four 6, five 6's, six 6's,
seven 6's, eight 6's.
So we're multiplying 6 by
itself eight times.
To write this in exponential
notation, we would say that
this is equal to 6 to the
eighth power, which is
literally equal to 6 times 6
times 6 times 6 times 6 times
6 times 6 times 6.
Now, I want to make it very
clear this is NOT, this is
NOT, this is NOT equal
to 6 times 8.
6 times 8 will only be 48.
6 to the eighth power is
a super huge number.
6 times 6 is 36, and you're
going to multiply that times
6, which is what?
That's like 36 times--
that's what?
216, and you keep multiplying
it by 6, you get some huge
number here.
This number right here.
It's worthwhile to point out
this number is huge.
This number right here,
not so huge.
It is not huge.
So don't get confused.
If you see 6 to the eighth
power, it's 6 times itself
eight times, not 6 times 8.